hey everyone if you are not a good Savvy
person if you are more into data and its
analysis then this video is for you
business analytics can make a difference
in the industry by enhancing customer
experience according to the U.S Bureau
of Labor Statistics the employment rate
of business analyst Will Rise by 11
between 2019 and 2039. organizations
hire business analyst as they play a
widened role in data-driven decisions
business analytics gives the
organization the Insight on how
companies can be more efficient it is
surprising that businesses that use
business analytics and are data driven
typically outperform their competitors
this is because the knowledge gathered
through business analytics allows them
to explore more efficient business
process understand why particular
results are produced and even predict
the possibility of specific outcomes in
this video we are going to discuss the
complete roadmap of a business analyst
but before moving forward please make
sure you subscribe to Simply learns
YouTube channel and never miss any
updates first is analytical and critical
thinking as a business analyst a first
thing to learn is analytics the needs of
the client must be clearly analyzed and
translated by the business analyst
before choosing the desired solution a
business analyst might evaluate a
variety of choices with the aid of
critical thinking business analysts
concentrate on learning about and
comprehending the needs of the light
they are able to prioritize business
requirements thanks to critical thinking
for analytics Excel is widely used you
can check out the skill up course Link
in the description box below for best
Excel course programming language
business analyst should be proficient
programmers in order to conduct data
analysis more quickly and effectively
understanding R and python is quite
helpful writing effective quotes can be
used to resolve complex issues
additionally business predictions can be
made using business models please check
out the courses on data science with
python or R language links for both the
courses are available in the description
box below next comes database and data
visualization most frequently business
analyst use structure data they should
be well versed in relational databases
like Microsoft SQL Server MySQL Oracle
DB as well as nosql databases in order
to store and process this large amount
of data Microsoft Excel proficiency is
the next ability on our list of business
analyst qualifications every business
analyst has to have this fundamental
ability for data visualization we opt
tools like power bi tab blue Microsoft
Excel Oracle analytics Etc among them
Tableau is very widely used it is very
easy to learn and handle you can check
out the skill up course on data
visualization by simply known given in
the description box below next is
communication skill this is necessary
for every business analyst to have
ability to understand the Corporate Way
of communicating information to make
decision and impact clients he should be
able to communicate with the
stakeholders easily so if you are an
aspiring business analyst start working
on your communication skills a business
analyst uses communication and
interpersonal skills at different phases
for example when a project is being
launched while collecting required
elements when collaborating with
stakeholders while validating the final
solution and so on ability to identify
quality business decisions a business
analyst choices can affect a company's
operations both directly and indirectly
they should therefore consider all the
factors before offering their choice a
business analyst analyzes the issue and
identifies potential business solutions
before making any choice they then put
each alternative strategy to the test
and decide based on their impressions of
these strategies finally they put the
solution to the test additionally
business analysts make the final
determination as to whether or not a
specific technological design matches
with the discussed business requirements
coming to presentation and documentation
a business analyst should thoroughly and
clearly describe the lessons learned and
project result in front of the
stakeholders and clients they should
convey their projects result and
outcomes with Assurance business analyst
can readily explain technological
Concepts to staff members who aren't
technically minded with the aid of
well-organized documentation discipline
and time management finally good
business analyst will be just based on
their time management as they will be
piled up with lot of tasks and
responsibilities best suitable tools for
managing time and activities would be
cheer up Tira software is a member of a
family of tools for managing projects in
teams of all sizes jeera was initially
intended to be a bug and issue tracker
today however jeera has developed into a
potent Work Management solution for a
variety of use cases including agile
software development and management of
requirements and test cases in order to
discover more about the Technologies you
are interested in and the free online
courses that are available here you can
visit the official skill up website you
can view these self-paced videos as many
times as you like to complete the
courses which are presented by the
subject the description below will
provide links to all the courses
mentioned so that brings us to the end
of our video on the roadmap to become
business analyst we hope you found this
video informative and we recommend you
leave your doubts and thoughts in the
comment section below thanks for
watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here